[Música]
he llegado aquí a Buenos Aires hace tres
días y la calor está
insoportable sofocosa agobiante te
desgasta las energías yo que estoy
acostumbrada Al calor en la isla del
Trópico en el Caribe este calor que he
sentido en estos días ha sido más fuerte
que cuando estoy en Puerto Rico Así que
te podrás imaginar como me siento de
cansada te desgasta
[Música]
ha habido días de mucho calor en marzo
pero no con la continuidad que ha sido
este año que ha sido creo que por los
últimos 15 o 20 años no ha habido tanto
calor
la casa
en realidad el calor afecta a la gente
Modesta gente Modesta sufre el calor
sufre el calor hay deshidratación ahí
sobre todo la gente de
pocos recursos y sobre todo los niños
hay muchos problemas de deshidratación
con los niños
[Música]